aquí tenemos un triángulo a veces lo que
quiero hacer en este vídeo es mostrar
que el círculo centro del triángulo es
decir el punto de intersección de las
tres media triz es el centro del eje es
tres medianas y el [ __ ] centro h o sea
el punto de intersección de las tres
alturas del triángulo son co lineales es
decir quiero ver que los puntos
h están en una misma recta otra forma de
pensarlo es que queremos ver que og y gh
son segmentos en el segmento o h vale
bueno para probar eso dibuje el
triángulo medial de f es decir d
efe son los puntos medios de los lados y
vamos a utilizar varias cosas que ya
sabemos acerca del triángulo medial para
empezar vamos a utilizar la semejanza
del triángulo abc con el triángulo de
efe y esta semejanza está en razón 2 a 1
eso ya lo vimos en un vídeo anterior
pero bueno para recordar esto de la
razón 2 a 1 quiere decir que si tomamos
una cierta distancia de puntos en el
triángulo abc y nos fijamos en la
distancia correspondiente de puntos en
el triángulo
efe entonces esas distancias están en
razón 2 a 1 muy bien vamos a utilizar
eso de ahí y además vamos a utilizar
otra propiedad que probamos vamos a
utilizar que o el círculo centro del
triángulo abc al mismo tiempo es el [ __ ]
centro del triángulo de e efe
aquí está escrito vale o es el circo un
centro de abc y el puerto centro del df
eso es algo que también ya probamos en
otro vídeo y de hecho de hecho lo
utilizamos para ver que las alturas de
un triángulo concurrían empezábamos con
el triángulo de ef trazamos sus alturas
trazamos el abc osea de tal forma que de
efe fuera el medial y las alturas del df
se convertían en las media tristes de
abc las cuales ya sabíamos que
concurrían y por lo tanto las alturas
del df con julia pero bueno lo
importante es recordar esto de que el
circo un centro del triángulo abc es el
[ __ ] centro del triángulo medial desde
bueno ahora sí vamos con el plan de la
demostración lo que nos gustaría probar
es lo siguiente nos gustaría probar una
semejanza de triángulos lo voy a poner
por acá nos gustaría probar que el
triángulo efe og efe
es semejante al triángulo
efe efe og semejante al triángulo c hg
el triángulo c hg porque nos gustaría
hacer esto imagínate que lo logramos
si así fuera entonces los ángulos
correspondientes serían congruentes
entonces el ángulo f
sería congruente al cg h y como tenemos
que cf si es una recta porque es la
mediana verdad y me pasa por qué porque
es el centro jde entonces la igualdad de
estos ángulos nos daría que o h si es
una transversal de adeveras es decir un
g h de adeveras es una recta vale otra
forma de pensarlo es con ángulos
opuestos por el vértice si este ángulo
es igual este de acá como esta de aquí
ya es una recta y estos son ángulos
opuestos por el vértice iguales entonces
h
o bueno también tendría que ser una
recta vale bueno entonces vamos a
intentar mostrar esta semejanza de acá
déjame empezar con unos ángulos veamos
que se x es perpendicular a b este x es
donde se h corta a ave y es
perpendicular porque ese h es una altura
del triángulo abs ya que h es [ __ ]
centro vale bueno entonces c x es
perpendicular a ave pero de manera
similar o efe es perpendicular a b
porque o efe es una media triz del
triángulo abs entonces tenemos que las
rectas
efe y c x son ambas perpendiculares a
ave y por lo tanto son paralelas entre
sí podemos pensarlo no sé a lo mejor con
ángulos correspondientes congruentes
vale bueno entonces eso lo que nos dice
es que el segmento lo voy a pintar con
color naranja nos dice que el segmento f
efe o el segmento de feo es paralelo al
segmento ch el segmento c h vale y de
esta de estos dos segmentos paralelos
podemos concluir la igualdad de los
ángulos alternos internos de alguna
transversal y la que sí sabemos que es
transversal es cf vale
ggf si es una recta es una mediana y es
transversal a efe o y a ch
entonces los ángulos alternos internos
son congruentes esto lo que quiere decir
es que este ángulo de acá es igual a
este ángulo de acá y en letras de eso es
que el ángulo o fg el ángulo o fg es
congruente
al ángulo hcg al ángulo
h ese eje muy bien entonces ya tenemos
una igualdad de ángulos en estos dos
triángulos parece ser que vamos bien
ahora vamos con un poco de razones
recordemos que el centro de un triángulo
divide a la mitad en dos segmentos que
están en razón dos a uno vale otra forma
en la cual lo decíamos es que está a dos
tercios de la mediana recorriendo del
vértice al punto medio pero bueno déjame
escribir eso por acá en algún lado lo
que acabo de decir es que se mide el
doble que gf entonces lo voy a poner a
15 g
cg que son una eso fue una je je je je
es igual a dos veces dos veces efe je
vale entonces éste es la mitad de este
de acá vale entonces como que se ve que
es lo que planeo hacer verdad ya mostré
que este el cg es el doble de fg ya
mostré que el ángulo o fg es congruente
al hsg entonces bastaría ver que ese h
es el doble de efe o para concluir que
estos dos triángulos
son semejantes con eso lograríamos que
lograríamos ver que dos parejas de
helados están en las son dos a uno y el
ángulo entre ellos el ángulo entre ellos
es el mismo y por lo tanto concluiríamos
que de a de veras son triángulos
semejantes entonces pues lo que nos
convendría es ver si la de veras ch es
el doble de efe pero pensemos un ratito
en quién es e h
ch es el segmento que va de el vértice
del triángulo a abc alberto centro h
va entonces va del vértice al [ __ ]
centro y quien este feo pues en el en el
triángulo de f también es un segmento
que va del vértice al [ __ ] centro porque
es el [ __ ] centro de d
efe entonces tenemos que son segmentos
correspondientes en los triángulos y por
lo tanto esos segmentos deben de estar
en razón 2 a 1 déjame escribirlo por acá
entonces vamos a ponerlo con otro color
verde si este verde se ve bien entonces
tenemos que se h
ch es el doble del doble de f
y déjame dejar esto esto clarísimo
porque esa es una idea este muy
importante para la demostración tenemos
que ese es el punto correspondiente a
efe en esta semejanza se es el
correspondiente a efe
pero además h es el otro centro de abc y
es el [ __ ] centro de d
efe entonces h es el punto
correspondiente ao en la semejanza de
esta forma el segmento c h
el segmento correspondiente al f o en la
semejanza y como los triángulos están en
razón 2 a 1 entonces se mide el doble de
f
vale bueno espero que esta explicación
ya haya sido mucho más clara eso es algo
súper importante bueno entonces que
logramos hasta ahorita ya logramos
mostrar que este segmento en el cg
mide lo doble que el jefe
ya también ya también mostramos que ese
h ch mide lo doble que f
lo doblé qué feo y finalmente finalmente
vimos que este ángulo entre esos lados
que ya vimos que están en razón 2 a 1 es
igual a este ángulo a este ángulo de acá
entonces eso está súper padre verdad
ahora podemos aplicar el criterio lado
ángulo lado de semejanza para concluir
para concluir la semejanza que queremos
entonces lo voy a poner aquí por el
criterio criterio lado ángulo lado de
semejanza tenemos tenemos que el
triángulo
efe
es que quedó horrible fg es semejante al
triángulo ce hg
hg y eso es justo lo que queríamos
probar ahora si el argumento se termina
como te decía hace rato ya que tenemos
que esos dos triángulos son semejantes
entonces sus ángulos correspondientes
son congruentes entonces el ángulo f
estoy acá es congruente al ch
a este de acá pero el más importante y
es el que nos ayuda a terminar la
demostración es el otro es decir que el
ángulo f
fg es congruente al ángulo cg h el
ángulo c
a este de acá bueno y de esta igualdad
de ángulos que voy a poner por acá el
ángulo éste
efe fg
frente al eje h al ángulo
cg h el argumento se termina como como
ya te dije tenemos tenemos que og h de
adeveras es una transversal o bien
pensándolo con ángulos opuestos por el
vértice estos dos ángulos son ángulos
opuestos al vértice g efe cda de veras
es una recta entonces tenemos que og h
deben de estar alineados vale entonces
esto está padrísimo esto no tiene aquí
una idea muy simple pero que es una idea
muy profunda siempre tenemos que decir
que un centro el centro hoy de y el [ __ ]
centro de un triángulo están alineados y
la recta maravillosa en la cual siempre
están se le conoce como la recta de hoy
leer